ان المملكه المتحده هي ممم مكان للافضل في
العالم ويمكن ان نفوز به سباق العالمي على
المهارات
وان نكون قادرين على التنافس وهنا يمكن ان
نحقق انجازنا لكن الاصعب هو التعامل مع
الهجره غير الشرعيه وهذا امر انا عازم على
اصلحه سؤال تاليمن
ان هناك
جديد حول الهجره وقال لنا نريد
همم
مساء الهجره
بعدم وجود عماله لابد من اصلاح قوانين
الهجره لاجل ذلك
اسمح لي ان اكون واضح في هذا الشان وتحتها
قيادته فان المملكه المتحده لن تسعى لاي
علاقات مع اوروبا انها
تحققوا مصالح لبلاد وبالتالي
لابد ان يكون لدينا سيطره على حدودنا
ويكون
وسنناقش مساله نوعيه الهجره التي نريدها
ونحن نسيطر على المساله الان عندما ياتي
الامر للتجاره يمكن ان نفتح
ابوابنا امام الاقتصادات والاسواق
العالميه عدت للتو من الاجتماع
التجاره العالميه هذه فرص رائعه لبريطانيا
وتحدثنا عن النمو واعتقد انكم سمعتم عن
الابتكار والابداع ونحن بحاجه قوانين
مناسبه للمستقبل لتضمن ان هذه البلاد تكون
قياده في هذا العالم لايجاد فرص العمل في
المستقبل وان يكون لدينا الحريه لتحقيق
هذه المصالح
الشعب في الايام القادمه
اكبر
ارتفاع في
الضريبه هل يمكن ان يكون هناك
تغيير للانظمه الاجرائيه
اهميه فتح
الاقتصاد الخاص
وان اردنا ان نكون رياضيين لابد نفكر بفرس
الاستثمار وليس فقط ما تحدثت عنه في همم
خطابي بل ايضا انسان همم مساله راس المال
وزيادته ولا بد من اتخاذ القرارات